what I want to figure out in this video
is the area under the curve y equals one
over x squared with one as with x equals
1 as our lower boundary and have no
upper boundary just keep on going
forever and forever as it really is
essentially as X approaches infinity so
I want to figure out what this entire
area is and one way that we can denote
that is with an improper definite
integral or an improper integral and we
would denote it as 1 is our lower
boundary but we're just going to keep on
going forever as our upper boundary so
our upper boundary is infinity and we're
taking the integral of 1 over x squared
DX and so let me be very clear this
right over here is an improper improper
improper integral now how do we actually
deal with this well by definition this
is the same thing as the limit as the
limit as n approaches infinity of the
integral from 1 to N of 1 over x squared
1 over x squared DX and this is nice
because we know how to evaluate this
this is just a definite integral where
the upper boundary is N and then we know
how to take limits we can figure out
what the limit is as n approaches
infinity so let's figure out if we can
actually evaluate this thing so over the
second fundamental theorem of calculus
so the second part of the fundamental
theorem of calculus tells us that this
piece right over here so let me write
the limit part so this part I'll just
rewrite the limit as n approaches
infinity of of and we're going to use
the second fundamental theorem of
calculus we're going to evaluate the
antiderivative of X of 1 over x squared
or X to the negative 2 so the
antiderivative of x to the negative 2 is
negative x to the negative 1 so negative
x to the negative 1 or negative 1 over X
so negative 1 over X is the
antiderivative and we're going to
evaluate it at N and evaluate it at 1 so
this is going to be equal to the limit
the limit as n approaches infinity
let's see if we evaluate this thing a 10
we get negative 1 over N so we get
negative 1 over N and from that we're
going to subtract this thing evaluated 1
so it's negative 1 over 1 or it's
negative 1 so this right over here is
negative 1 and so we're going to find
the limit as n approaches infinity of
this business this stuff right here is
just this stuff right here I haven't
found the limit yet
so this is going to be equal to the
limit as n approaches infinity let's see
this is positive 1 positive 1 and we
could even write that minus 1 over n of
1 minus 1 over N and lucky for us this
limit actually exists limit as n
approaches infinity this term right over
here is going to get closer and closer
and closer to zero 1 over infinity you
can essentially view as zero so this
right over here is going to be equal to
1 which is pretty neat we have this area
that has no right boundary just keeps on
going forever but we still have a finite
area and the area is actually exactly
equal exactly equal to 1 so in this case
we had an improper integral and because
we were actually able to evaluate it and
come up with a number that this limit
actually existed we say that this
improper integral right over here is
convergent convergent if for whatever
reason this was unbounded we couldn't
come up with some type of a finite
number here if the area was infinite we
would say that it is divergent so right
over here we were figuring we figured
out a kind of neat thing this area is
exactly 1